my goal was always to be in the u.n i
thought i was gonna be a diplomat
um i threw that in the trash but but the
storytelling
aspect of it all i think does actually
run deep and there is
a real common denominator between uh the
things that i've done
[Music]
yeah western lovely thank you so much
for being on my show i'm so incredibly
excited to have you here
i am too thanks for having me michael
i've been waiting for this for a long
time you're one of the most wanted
you know high-tech entrepreneurs
communications writers whatever you
wouldn't call it in the world because
the work that you've been doing with
well yes it just shows by me getting
ahold of you and every person that i
talk to says
how amazing you are because the work
that you've done with lemonade with
the with being vice president of
communications there in a company that
is revolutionizing the way that
you know content is being delivered in
the world of insurance and i'm
now in the insurance space with hippo
insurance so i get to appreciate
this art of communications and content
there it's remarkable but i actually
know you back from your speech writing
days and previously
as a news anchor so you have a breadth
of
of experience in in the world of
communication zl take me back to
the good old days you're back with
channel 10 news and then i-24 news
why journalism why communications i
i will take you definitely back um but i
have to
comment on those crazy crazy compliments
you gave earlier i can't take any of the
credit i work with
an incredible team and i know hippo also
has a
really outstanding team but here at
lemonade i've been fortunate enough to
work with
really the the best entrepreneurs i
think on the planet
um and learning from them and just kind
of
being here for five years i'm actually
celebrating my five year anniversary
here at lemonade it has been
an unbelievable journey uh on a personal
level
as well yeah but also on a professional
level really working side by side with
with the top of the the best
like really really uh top talent um but
we'll get to that
um yeah as you mentioned i had a
unorthodox way of jumping into
the tech scene um but i like to say that
if you look back and try to connect the
dots
it's actually very clear it just wasn't
clear at the time when i was in my 20s
and i was going through as you said
journalism to politics back to
journalism
back to politics um it was it looked
like i was like you know hopping around
whereas
i feel like i was just you know diving
deeper and deeper into this
world of storytelling um and
storytelling is actually the elements of
it are
pretty basic and you put it in
journalism or you put it in politics or
you put it in tech
and the very kind of elements and the
fundamentals of storytelling are the
same
and um i started my storytelling
experience if you will
um right after the army
uh here in israel actually even before
like
i was i grew up in a home that was um
very much of a storyteller's home um
books and stories and and my mother's a
teacher as you know
um were part of the everyday life um
and i always i always like to write and
and kind of delve into that um after the
army i worked in
the u.s congress for a democrat from new
york
um and that's where i was exposed for
the first time to storytelling kind of
as a profession
that was beyond just like the you know
what i've known
before that as you know authors and and
so forth
uh suddenly i saw all these you know
members of congress that would
come into the senate or the house and
they wouldn't say a word without having
their speech try to write it for them
and it wasn't because they were
incompetent they were actually they're
extremely incompetent individuals and
i was lucky enough to work with um
representative steve israel
from new york but they understood the
power of the word and the power of
everything that they were saying
um had they had the opportunity to
change
hearts and minds they had the
opportunity to get bills passed they had
the opportunity
um to get votes for their legislation
but whatever it was they understood that
there was an opportunity here and
there's an opportunity that could not be
missed and if you have that opportunity
to have that time you have the attention
of someone
in front of you how do you use it to
optimize what you're saying
so that people want to hear you and
active activate or go out and implement
what you just said
and uh that that fascinated me that kind
of very ideas
it's really human behavior of how we
internalize something and we decide to
go do something because
we read it or we saw it or were actually
you know looking at someone as a role
model and
trying to replicate or emulate them um
and representative israel congressman
israel was
really uh he saw this on in me and i saw
and i was
itching to write and it was the year
after
the second lebanese war and he was uh
putting through a lot of
legislation in congress around um the
end of the
the war and i i asked to write some of
his speeches i also like input
a lot of uh what he would be saying on
the floor of the house
um and that's where it kind of started
from there i went into haaretz
um and was a editor on the website for
three years
and then went to channel 10 here in
israel which is now channel 13.
um right and uh 24 news
and then i-24 news um studied in london
i i my goal was always to be in the u.n
i thought i was going to be a diplomat
um i threw that in the trash but
but the storytelling aspect of it all i
think does
actually run deep and there is a real
common denominator between
uh the things that i've done so if i if
i can even say anything that i learned
from that is
you know everything will make sense in
the end that you if you follow
kind of your passion and continue doing
things that you like you don't need to
create your resume in advance you
actually you look back and you'll say
wow that
actually really does make sense yeah the
very first thing that he said was
storytelling it's
it's pretty basic and it's roots but i
have to tell you i took a class
very recently at stanford with david
demerist he was a senior staff for the
white house for george bush
senior and and we got we had dinner a
few times and the stories that he told
me about the responsibility he wrote
most of the speeches for george bush the
senior
and the the responsibility and the
burden of being the storyteller
with the nuances and you wrote speeches
for heads of state
presidents ceos right and so it's not
just
telling taking the content and putting
in the nice way but it's actually the
art of delivering it and convincing
others
in your message and and i can only
imagine you know the responsibility
and the anxiousness of watching them
deliver the speech and seeing the
reactions because we can see
especially in 2020 with the elections on
all sides
how every speech every debate is so
fundamentally crucial
to the position of the candidates that i
can only imagine
the skills that you have to build and
what's remarkable i think about your
journey that i'm getting a lot of
inspiration from
is i see a trend today that people are
moving very very quickly between domains
as if it's like a check box
and while you've moved quite a bit from
different domains
you've really dug deep into them you've
spent you know five to seven years
in in editing and journalism and then in
speech writing and now
in high tech five years spending in in a
hyper growth startup
that's that's incredible so so while you
did change
you really dug deep into all of those
subjects do you feel that way
yes and i think i do in retrospect i
don't i don't claim to have known all of
this
ahead of time i didn't go out and say
i'm going to spend five years here i
mean had you asked me
uh six years ago if i if if i thought
i'd be working in an insurance company i
would have thought you were
absolutely crazy um that wasn't on my
grand scheme of things but
i can say that um one thing i have
learned and this is only in retrospect
so everything
we're all so smart in retrospect is that
the focus and kind of when you kind of
focus on one or two skills that you want
to
hone on and understand and get really
good at
um you have to there's there's only
focus you can't
spread yourself too thin you have to
know what you're good at and what you
want to get better at and i think i'm a
true believer in getting better at stuff
that you're not great at
um but i also think that when you focus
on something and you don't try to
win it all um you get to you get to
interesting results uh so what are you
really good at
what are you what is your focus
so i think i think i'm i'm trying to
understand
the flexibility and the dynamics of
storytelling to its
core um i was as i said like when i was
just starting out i was absolutely sure
i was going to be a journalist forever
and then that kind of turned into well
journalism is great and i
and i you know i i think i can give a
lot and learn a lot
but i don't think it's actually going to
change policy and then i wanted very
much to go into the foreign service and
and be a diplomat and i went to i went
to school in london
thinking that that would be like my next
the next stop uh before the u.n or
something like that
and i think um understanding in london
my understanding there was um sure you
can go into the foreign service but
actually as you said the person really
helping some of the leaders
formulate their policy are these you
know ghostwriters or speechwriters or
whatever you'd like to call them
and so that fascinated me i said you
know it's not only about the words it's
about who you're working with and i was
fortunate enough to work with really top
leaders here in israel writing their
speeches in english
and then that that kind of relationship
also um really fascinated me because i
said
wow if you take that relationship you
put it to business to public companies
and you work with you know ceos of a
public company
on formulating their message how are
they going to
speak when they have earnings calls and
stuff like that um
that really fascinated me as well and i
was fortunate to work with the
ceo of teva pharmaceuticals for a while
and i started adding on clients and in
business
not only in politics and understanding
that in terms of
you know the storytelling if i go back
to what i started with this is this is
fascinating this is something that you
know
you keep on learning and learning
learning and if i can focus on that
and get better and kind of expand my
knowledge in
um the storytelling realm by working
with different
leaders i really will expand my
knowledge base in general
and then it was it was pretty clear to
me after a few years doing that that
technology and silicon valley was where
maybe policy was even trumping uh a lot
of things that are
in government and no pun intended that
didn't sound very good very
now but um i did i did kind of feel like
i wanted to join something that was
bigger than what i could do by myself
we're going to dive into it but i have
to ask before that because i i
i need you to take us into the mind of
this storyteller for a second because
you know the majority of the people
listening to this including myself are
young scrappy hungry entrepreneurs that
are that are
you know we tell ourselves stories and
we and we think of the world and
we keep trying to reinvent things that
are happening around us
yet i'd love to learn a little bit from
you when you approach a story whether
it's
writing it helping write a speech for a
president or for a ceo
or for a limited what what are what is
some of the thought process that goes
into building this narrative
that at the end others want to follow
and i'm generally asking this because
i'm curious to
what constitutes a good story a good
narrative
so i think the one of the first things
that you have to think about when you're
writing anything and is is who you're
writing for who are the audience and
what do you want them to feel what do
you want them to take away from it
because everyone has
you know especially now like zero
attention span
um people people are on the go they're
getting their information
in 10 different ways that you didn't you
didn't even optimize for
um right so you're trying to when you're
trying to write something you really
need to narrow down
this it goes back to the focus like
focus on who exactly you want to be
reading this and what
they want to be feeling or what you want
them to be feeling
and when you have that in mind you can
kind of create that story in a way that
makes sense not for you a lot of times
we're writing and we think
this is my story sure it may be your
story but if you want people to go and
and execute on that story or
buy your product or believe in you and
vote for you or whatever it is
that you want them to do you really have
to think about them um and what they're
feeling
and and kind of create that story for
them and not for you and i think that's
a lot you know
it's kind of counter-intuitive because
you're you know you open up your google
docs and you start typing and you feel
like you're
sharing who you are but it's actually
not really about you it's about your end
customer
whether that be your constituent or your
um or your or your parents if you're you
know whatever it is who who is this
audience
um and then the second thing that i
would say is that because we have such a
short attention span
you need content you need stories or
data points or whatever
it is that you're constructing that
sticky content they call it and
something that
you know people will walk away if they
can remember one thing from what you
just wrote or what you just said
or or the graph or the infographic that
you made
what will that be um and sometimes you
need to shock them sometimes it needs to
be something that is
actually inspiring and not just fluffy
content which a lot of people like to
you know you oh i read a nice quote
somewhere let me put it in but nobody
really
remembers it like what is a sticky part
of your content that you're going to be
leaving the audience with um i guess
that would be my two
how do you how do you know that so when
i'm sitting down and i'm preparing
a talk or i'm preparing a letter how how
do i know
if something is going to stick do you do
you test it out before
do you get feedback from others and how
do you run all those experiments because
that sounds complicated it is it's a lot
of
trial and error and it's a lot of
getting to know your audience so
sometimes you'll write something and
it'll fall flat
so sometimes people will like that
they'll say okay i wrote something
people read it but it didn't do anything
and sometimes that's like comforting
because
okay it didn't move the needle but at
least it didn't get anyone angry
on the other hand if you take more risks
and you're you go out on a limb
and you say i'm not gonna speak to
everyone i'm gonna speak to
you know two percent of my audience
because i know that those two percent
are the most engaged and they will
follow me and they'll come after
me if i ask them to um you know you see
that a lot in politics
it's not only i was just about to say i
mean we're watching it unfold live
these different tactics right and so and
so you don't wanna you can't win
everyone and you can't win the hearts
and minds of everyone
but if you go and you say something that
will you know make
someone's ears perk up and another
person and another person's
you're probably going to get a more
engaged audience than if you say
you know kind of the cliche that
everyone's used to
um and so that's you have to be a risk
taker it's a lot a lot of risk and be
prepared to kind of own what you're
saying
so when you sit down and listen to a
speech when you watch the news or when
you're
listening to somebody talk do you cringe
sometimes like do you ha
are you do you have like wheels and
motions saying like oh this is the
tactic that they're using they're
alluding to something bigger they're
trying to get me to feel
these emotions do you have that process
yeah
sometimes i try to take it off because
you know you don't want to become too
cynical like you wanna
believe that there's you know the
cynicism will
at the end you know really make us uh
not optimistic to be so i wanna keep the
hope alive i wanna think that
you know that there are people that are
speaking genuinely and they're not
trying to
you know you know artificially implant
all kinds of like speaking tactics and
rhetoric and stuff like that
and i do believe that there are people
out there that are speaking from their
their heart and their brain and not just
trying to um
rouse up the crowds um but yes you can't
ignore it once you see it
it's like you can't unsee it i i love it
yeah
so vice president of communications at
lemonade hyper growth startup you're
joining very from the early days and
that's a fascinating
thing because you're coming in from the
the political world right into
high tech what is that experience like
and what what what
what was the journey like reinventing
the messaging behind
insurance so as i said from the start i
really am privileged to be able to work
with two of the
finest entrepreneurs that i can think of
today daniel schreiber and chai weninger
um they were tech veterans and they had
been around
been around the tech scene so to speak
and when they stopped at insurance they
found an opportunity that really was
this huge opportunity because it was so
unchanged it had gone through
decades if not centuries of of
stagnation
it was so unloved you know when they
came and when i heard about
insurance for the first time through
lemonade i said you know that sounds
like
i don't know it can't be something
compelling
um but they found but that actually you
know the fact the fact that it was
unchanged and unloved was
a huge market opportunity and a huge
storytelling opportunity
because suddenly you can change the
perception of something that is really
such a fundamental part of society right
when something goes wrong you want to
make sure that you have something
to to cover you um and why did it go
why did it lose its way what happened to
that story of insurance that started
really as communities coming together
and really lost its way um through
through the kind of evolution of society
it kind of really ignored
every other revolution that went through
insurance stayed the same
um and i think that part of the story of
you know
taking on an industry that was so vast
um
but also so unloved is like a
storyteller's
dream it's a it's a it's an entrepreneur
dream it's a
it's a product dream right you can go
you can see it through any lens that
you'd like
um but really uh understanding the
opportunity here
uh both to work with daniel and chai and
the rest of the team
and also understanding the opportunity
at hand for the world
lemonade is also a b corporation so
understanding that we're a for-profit
business but
we have like social good embedded in our
business model with something that
um i wanted to be part of that story i
wanted to tell that story
um and as i said you know joining
something that is bigger than the sum of
yourself is really gratifying in the end
if it works and if even if it doesn't
work it's great and
it almost it's almost like the ultimate
challenge for a storyteller because
you're literally
trying to change the perception of what
it means to be insurance because
just like yourself i think the majority
of the people they think of insurance
until today and they think of
like okay this is the enemy they're
trying to take my money and maybe if i
can
maybe if i have an accident i can
finally get the money back from them
right it's almost like a win in front of
your insurance company and also in here
you're trying to
to work on a startup that is trying to
create a social contract with insurance
what was the biggest challenge there
with sort of trying to reinvent that
messaging
so it's everything that you said like
how do we make insurance
interesting for for people that never
really either liked insurance or
or in our case especially people that
never had insurance before
um you know we a lot of our our
customers are first-time insurance
buyers meaning they never ever had
insurance and
what why what will make them want to
come to lemonade um and
we talk about lemonade in general and
insurance i think hippo does
also similar uh messaging is you know
is understanding that um insurance can
be lovable it can be spoken about in a
way
that nobody ever dared to speak about it
before and when we launched in new york
in
september 2016 we started seeing people
tweet about their
lemonade experience being delightful and
amused and
is it weird that i love my insurance
company and it started ringing also back
to us saying you know we're on to
something and
if we make an experience that is
absolutely delightful from start to
finish
that is seamless and fun and and brings
smiles to people's
faces and they can choose a charity that
they'd like to support
then we're really kind of changing the
entire fundamentals of insurance um not
just the financials but really how
people
interact with it and and that's a kind
of the ultimate story
no and obviously i think from from the
sudden i've been following the journey
for a long time there's so many
different facets that you've employed
in order to change that narrative
starting from the transparency
of being fully transparent from day zero
and you know you when you think of
insurance you think of this like big mom
so that's like
getting all the cash and all of a sudden
you're being transparent about the
financials and
about the intentions and and i think
that i gained a lot of inspiration
and i'm you know i'm delighted to be now
with a self-bonded hippo and seeing also
how
how you know the different companies
somehow all of them are israelis but
also next insurance
they're coming in and all of a sudden
such a big field is changing
so dramatically and and at the end it's
for the benefit of a lot of people it's
for the benefit of millions of people
but unfortunately i can't believe 20
minutes are almost up i have about 100
different questions that i wanted to ask
here
yeah i i want to thank you so much for
being on the show and i really
appreciate it back from when
you you very generously donated your
time to come to one of my debate
programs our debate clubs at school to
teach us about storytelling and
and that was one of the most inspiring
sessions that we had and i've been in
that i was in that club for about five
years
and so thank you going all the way back
there and before we leave
i have to ask you for three words that
you would use to describe yourself
oh you ask tough questions
uh the hardest one yeah it is i don't i
i don't want to self describe but i can
tell you the three things that i
kind of really admire and i hope that i
use in my when i'm with my team um
and they know this and so i'm happy to
kind of spread spread it around but
the three things that i really admire in
in a person and a leader
are resilience integrity
and compassion and i think that the
the three of them together really kind
of uh
touch upon different aspects of of of
leadership but also of human behavior
that
is crucial um especially especially in
especially thank you so much i can't
wait to share this with the world
and and best of luck with everything
that you're doing thank you